[Music]
on this Friday Night American approval
to import Canadian medicine Florida gets
US Federal permission to get
Pharmaceuticals from north of the border
the long- demanded policy change that
could impact
Canadians Soul Survivor the piercing
words in Port of an 11-year-old boy
whose family was killed in an attack on
Muslims he has the greatest loss here
his parents his sister his grandmother
plus a Canadian Soldier defending
Ukraine this is not a morally unclear
war and I knew that I could help the
Ontario man risking it all on the front
lines to fight Russia's Invasion and a
closer look at the deadly collision at a
Tokyo Airport how so many lives were
saved and what does it mean for air
travel safety in
Canada global national with far anaser
reporting tonight Carolyn Jarvis
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with a groundbreaking
decision in the US that could impact
Canadians Florida has become the first
state to get FDA approval to mass import
prescription drugs from wholesalers here
where prices are much lower a recent
survey shows Americans who ordered their
prescriptions from Canadian pharmacies
saved nearly $5,000 last year US states
have long fought to purchase medicines
in bulk to reain in some of the highest
drug prices in the world Mackenzie
reports on the policy shift and the
potential impact in
Canada a decades long dream could soon
becoming true for some unwell Americans
the US Food and Drug Administration
approving a request to have Canadian
drugs shipped to Florida in bulk to help
cut down on Skyhigh us prices Florida uh
population is you know half the size of
the Canadian one this is not a small
jurisdiction the Sunshine State will now
be allowed to buy large quanti ities of
canadian-made generic drugs that treat
illnesses like HIV AIDS diabetes and
hepatitis C and eight other states are
looking to follow suit but the impact on
Canadians is likely to be limited for
now thanks to a regulation Ottawa
implemented in 20120 prohibiting the
sale of medicine meant for the Canadian
Market that's in short supply enforcing
new rules on drug wholesalers if you
know that there's any drug that there
you could reasonably know would be in
shortage in Canada and you have
obligation not to export it if that
doesn't stop their export American Drug
manufacturers will also try with
expected Court challenges to the new FDA
rules is subject of tremendous
litigation by some of the most litigious
and well financed companies in America
if not the world so this is probably not
going to affect us too greatly too
quickly three major uh drug companies
who produce insulin a long-standing
policy on the American left Vermont
Senator Bernie Sanders since the 19
1990s has been busing people to Windsor
Ontario to buy medications for
substantially less American drugs are on
average 28% more expensive compared to
Canadian counterparts but it was Sanders
political polar opposite Florida is
going to buy a lot of these for our
programs Florida governor and Republican
Presidential nominee Ron DeSantis who
went to court to bring in these new
rules but they're unlikely to drive
prices down in order for American drug
prices to come down significantly we
American policy makers to really go
toe-to-toe with industry the health
Minister's office told Global News
Canadians would continue to have access
to the drugs that they need but his own
Department admits that's not happening
right now Carolyn over 1,800 drugs are
considered to be facing acute
shortage McKenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
Mackenzie it was a heart-wrenching day
in an Ontario courtroom as the words of
an 11-year-old boy the sole survivor of
an attack that killed three generations
of his family were heard the boy's
Victim Impact statement was one of
roughly 70 at the sentencing hearing for
Nathaniel veltman who targeted the afol
family with this truck in June of 2021
because they were Muslim Global sha oay
was in the London courtroom today
Sean Carolyn it was an emotional end to
this part of the Nathaniel veltman case
a landmark trial putting cidus terrorism
laws under the microscope now Nathaniel
veltman was convicted on four charges of
first-degree murder in no for killing
four members of the avol family here in
London Ontario prosecutors say that that
was an act of terrorism now jury had
found he had intentionally run down the
family in June of 21 uh when they were
out for a walk and that the family was
targeted uh because they were Muslim and
we heard from a lot of people over these
last few days a total of about 70 uh
including a victim a friend of a victim
uh saying that she is haunted by this
nightmare that just won't go away many
told the the court that they're afraid
to wear traditional Muslim clothing
they're afraid to cross the street they
talked about a loss of Innocence they
talked about the fact that they don't
think Canada is as tolerant as they once
thought it was but the last of the
roughly 70 statements that we heard here
was from an 11-year-old boy the only
surviving person in that attack whose
mother father sister and grandmother
were all killed we're not naming him
because of his age the boy suffered
serious injuries including a broken leg
and a broken collar bone he said in the
statement which was read by another boy
surrounded by supporters in part the
offense has made me very sad that the
fact that I can't talk to my family
anymore and make new memories with them
I won't be able to have fun with them
anymore now the leader of a London
Mosque reflected on what it meant for
the boy to make that statement we're all
here to support him
um he what he has to say will put like
will bring together all of our
sentiments because he his pain is the
most intense the boy said he misses his
grandmother's cooking and he understands
now why he had to do all that homework
even though his parents were trying to
get him away from video games the next
part of this trial takes place January
the 23rd velman will have an opportunity
to speak to the court if he wants then
he'll be sentenced but he'll be getting
25 years at least in jail that's the
mandatory minimum for first-degree
murder carlyn back to you Shan O'Shea in
London Ontario thanks
Shan after months of of job growth in
Canada the jobless rate stalled last
month according to statistics Canada the
unemployment rate was virtually
unchanged in December holding steady at
5.8% the economy added just 100 jobs but
there was a jump in average hourly wages
economists say it marks the biggest wage
gain in more than a year and could mean
employers are paying more to retain
workers ahead of a possible economic
downturn as an gaviola explains that may
help solve a different problem plaguing
Canada declining producct
ity we measure productivity in the
business World by cars manufactured
meals served it's the amount of goods
and services produced for every hour
worked across Canada economists say we
have a productivity problem another word
for for productivity is often
competitiveness productivity in Canada
has been on the decline for a year and a
half there are a few main reasons why
Canada doesn't have an economy on the
same scale as the US buiness business
experts also point to a lack of
competition in many key Industries not a
lot of incentive to go the extra mile
and analysts point to a regulatory
environment that holds up project
approvals another piece of the puzzle a
lack of investment in new ways of doing
things from more efficient equipment to
Automation and disruptive technology
imagine if I were working uh at
essentially you know in construction
with a shovel versus somebody working
with a backo a more recent factor is an
influx of newcomers from temporary
foreign workers to refugees immigration
has been a boon to GDP helping to fill
labor shortages but employment analysts
say integrating them into the labor
market with jobs that match their
strengths has been our Achilles heel if
newcomers are going into low paying jobs
if they're going into jobs that don't
really require uh significant skill sets
that sort of effect can actually erode
productivity with an economic slow down
underway companies are finding ways to
get more out of their Workforce holding
off on hiring but more willing to
increase pay employers are still willing
to hold on to their workers because
we've come off of such a tight labor
market that may be a boost to
productivity which benefits everyone
since the end of the second world war
80% of the rise of the standard of
living of Canadians has come through
stronger productivity an gaviola Global
News
Toronto at least one person is dead and
11 others injured after a bus heading
from Montreal to New York crashed this
afternoon New York State Police are
investigating the deadly bus rollover
happened about 260 kilometers south of
Montreal in the adarand region there
were 23 people on the bus at the time
New York's Governor called the rollover
horrific adding that New Yorkers are
praying for everyone involved on the eve
of the third anniversary of the violent
riot at the US capital President Joe
Biden made his first campaign speech of
the 2024 election warning that former
president Donald Trump's plans to retake
the White House pose a grave threat to
America Donald Trump's campaign is about
him not America not you he's willing to
sacrifice our democracy put himself in
power our campaign is
different speaking in Pennsylvania Biden
says January 6th 2021 marked a moment
where we nearly lost America Trump
supporters attempted to to stop Congress
from certifying Biden's 2020 election
win Biden says the 2024 presidential
race is all about whether American
democracy Will Survive he says he vows
to defend protect and preserve it the US
Secretary of State has touched down in
Turkey ahead of an expected stop in
Israel as fears of a wider regional
conflict intensify Anthony blinkin is
trying to broker a solution to end
Israel's war in Gaza after Israel
outlined its post-war plan that
envisions a Gaza without Hamas and
limited Palestinian rule blinkin is also
working to stop escalating attacks on US
troops and ships in the Red Sea by
iranian-backed militias without fueling
a wider war and as the fighting rages on
in Gaza the Israeli Defense Force
yesterday released more video that it
says shows Hamas tunnels in Han
Yunis also in Han yunas is a Canadian
doctor who traveled to help with gaza's
emergency response yaser Khan is an
opthalmologist from Ontario he's working
at a hospital there with a team of
doctors from Canada and the US
performing complex operations on wounded
Palestinians here is Dr Khan in his own
words the human tragedy is is so huge
here almost every hour someone's coming
in with an explosive injury or a serious
injury people are losing their legs
their eyes their lives the healthcare
workers are working here 24 hours every
single day with nothing with no
resources nothing no no
medications uh anesthetics everything is
out the healthcare workers here are
excellent and they're doing the best job
that they can despite the fact that the
system is
collapsing we had to bring her in
yesterday at about 8:00 p.m. and take
the eye out I think that really affected
me because it's a child and a child is
completely innocent and has done nothing
to deserve this I've seen more trauma
when it comes to eyes than I've ever
seen in my entire entire 20 years of
practice every hour or so we hear bombs
the hospital shakes the people of Gaza
the Palestinians here just go about
living their lives saving lives doing
procedures and almost ignoring the bombs
that are going on in the background and
I think because the people of Gaza are
so calm about it it calms me as
well that was Dr yaser Khan in Han Yunis
Gaza a Canadian in the trenches of
Ukraine up the Ontario soldier who
traveled to the front lines to fight
Russia's
Invasion a Ukrainian parliamentary
committee met this week to review
proposed changes to military draft rules
as a country looks for more soldiers to
fight Russia's Invasion bolstering
domestic ranks are hundreds of foreign
Fighters including some from Canada Dave
Smith who lives in Ottawa quit his role
with the Canadian Armed Forces to join
the front lines our red Shannon sat down
with him while he was in London on a
break from the
fighting I brought my helmet my
PL now everybody good Speedy yeah Speedy
okay my ears are ringing 20th century
trench warfare in 21st century Ukraine
at a certain point everything just
becomes like surreal and hilarious you
know like I just had to go pee and now
there's 122 mm shell flying over my head
Canadian Dave Smith is on leave from
Ukraine's Armed Forces while fighting on
the front lines in eastern Ukraine
several men in his unit have died yet he
will return to Ukraine later this month
he decided to end a 15year career with
the Canadian Armed Forces last year in
order to join a fight he believed in
passionately I never really had to give
um anyone a reason uh and all the
reasons I gave my wife she accepted but
we're still upset about this is not a
morally unclear War
um and I knew that I could help zero
this is 23 Alpha we just had one round
land like 2 m behind the position
they're getting increasingly closed are
you having any luck with that drone over
the Toronto native is fighting in a
mostly bellian unit he says his comrades
see Ukraine's future intertwined with
that of their own country which is firm
under moscow's influence the only
difference between you know training in
Canada versus fighting Ukraine is the
mud in Ukraine like defies physics this
is what the mud looks like in the trench
it gets everywhere it's on everything it
slows you down to the point where
neither us nor the Russians can really
maneuver I have told numerous people
this back in the Canadian Armed Forces
all those years when I was going through
the Infantry school we were always like
this is stupid we're never going to do
this again like and all the old guys who
remembered the Cold War were like no you
have to practice clearing trenches and
they were right and I was wrong it's
that simple Vladimir Putin calls
soldiers like Smith mercenaries he is
paid by Ukraine but only a fraction of
his Canadian military salary average
ukrainians are always thankful you get a
lot of handshaking hugging um old ladies
making sure you have somewhere something
to eat and somewhere to stay
oh yeah they're back close Smith says
Canada and the West cannot afford to
Tire in fighting against Russia's
Ambitions just cuz you're morally right
like Ukraine's the righteous side of
this war and we should all be supporting
them that doesn't mean we have unlimited
155 shells for them you know um so if if
you want to stop people who think might
makes right you also have to be pretty
Mighty Redmond Channon Global News news
London keeping Canadian runways safe
ahead could a deadly Collision like what
happened in Japan happened
[Music]
here we're starting to learn more
tonight about what led to a deadly crash
at Tokyo's hanada airport on Tuesday
recovery Crews began removing the
wreckage from the runway today five crew
members on board a Coast Guard Plane
were killed when it was hit by a
commercial jet coming in for landing all
300 79 passengers on board that flight
evacuated safely as neug Gara reports
it's prompting new questions about how
many close calls there are on Canadian
runways 1 in 11 million which is the
probability of any person being involved
in a a crash Nigel Waterhouse who works
in transport Canada's design approval
Department says extensive testing of
aircraft like this Japan Airlines plane
helped ensure all 300 79 passengers on
board got off alive after Tuesday's
crash at Japan's hanada
airport everything inside airplane is
tested and it it doesn't burn the
aircraft cabin is designed so that all
of the passengers well everybody can get
off within 90 seconds the widebody
jetliner was Landing when it collided
with a coast guard turbo prop which
sources say had been stopped on the
runway for nearly 40 seconds the Japan
Airlines jet kept advancing on the
carmac until it came to a standstill the
Coast Guard -8 had entered the runway
without permission from Air Traffic
Control five of the six crew members on
the Coast Guard Plane were killed an
investigation into the Collision is
underway I'm sure what we're going to
find in this investigation is that the
flight crew fully believed that they
were doing the right thing so the
question then is can we drill down far
enough to find out what it was that made
this seem correct as far as whether
something like what happened happened in
Japan could happen at Canadian airports
according to the Transportation safety
board of Canada the runway incursion
rate in this country doubled in the last
decade from an average of 5.3 incursions
per 100,000 arrivals and departures in
2010 to an average of 10.7 in 2021 those
numbers they cover all airplanes not
just passenger commercial traffic I
think there's a lot of near misses that
people don't NE so you know about as for
why air traffic controllers in Japan
didn't see the Coast Guard aircraft this
retired NAV Canada manager says it can
be hard to see really often you look out
and all you see is a blinking light in a
sea of hundreds of other lights
including taxi whe lights and Runway
lights this is the initial contact of
the dash a to the tower so basically
announced he's on Taxi wayc reviewing
transcripts of the conversations with
the control tower Waterhouse points out
the language wasn't clear departing
traffic is present so Japan Airlines
knew that there's another aircraft which
is in the vicinity which is getting
ready to depart he'll be watching the
investigation closely as officials aim
to complete the removal of the wreckage
this weekend Nea Global News
Vancouver lost in loneliness next the
Toronto Hospital tackling the health
issue head
[Music]
on
in a world where people can connect with
each other in so many different ways
loneliness is a growing concern for
Doctors medical professionals say
feelings of isolation can be associated
with poor health especially among
seniors Katherine Ward shows us how One
hospital is trying to help those in
need Andrew Taylor has volunteered at
Mount siai Hospital in Toronto for 14
years can I help you sir over the last
year Taylor's role has expanded from
providing directions to also calling
people doctors believe are at risk of
loneliness basically a a contact uh for
people who are uh socially isolated uh
because they're recovering from a
procedure or a clinic of some kind um
and they're at home and often live alone
Dr jacqu Lee is leading a new program at
Mount Si and says loneliness is a
critical Health concern this is nothing
I ever learned in medical school this is
nothing we've been trained to ask about
or inquire and we really don't know how
to prescribe for it either so it's a
hugely impactful health problem that
we're not monitoring volunteers are
paired with older patients who have
similar interests calls are scheduled
once a week for 3 months they're trying
to encourage them to get out make some
goals for themselves to try and be a
little bit more connected Lee says
loneliness needs to be viewed with a
medical lens people may have health
problems that they don't connect to the
fact that they're lonely Taylor says the
program has been mutually beneficial
it's kind of a an escape for both of us
too I mean I I think I got as much out
of it as as the patient Lee says a full
analysis of the program will be done
this spring he's hopeful the data will
yield positive results the fact that
it's such a big problem and we've never
done anything about it is actually an
opportunity because that means that hey
anything we do is going to move the bar
it's going to make it a little bit
better Katherine Ward Global News
Toronto
and that is global national for this
Friday I'm Carolyn Jarvis tonight's your
candidate is Regina's new feathery
representative Saskatchewan's Capital
unveiled its official bird today the
black capped Chickity more than 21,000
votes were cast in a contest that began
after Regina was declared a bird
friendly City by Nature Canada thanks
for watching far is back at the desk
tomorrow have a good
night
[Music]